hello folks welcome to rational science
we have a great day today we're going to
be doing a little recap
of what we did in the month of february
i'm going to start with the uh war
that's going on over there in ukraine
very hot on the news
and here are some of the headlines that
you'll read out there okay last couple
days ukrainian pilots arrive in poland
to pick up donated fighter jets
and then ukraine president asked for
fast-track eu membership
then we have the mail online the
guardian they both say that belarus may
be about to send its troops into ukraine
okay
and uh
fox news denies it says uh
kiev's uh claimed that belarus and
troops uh joined russia's invasion of
ukraine
and
says it's false
and
then the washington post mentions that
the ukrainians are asking for a no-fly
zone over ukraine meaning they want the
united states to get in into the war
okay
and as far as the pilots arriving in
poland and taking uh
jets into
ukraine uh that's also been
denied by
many outlets okay
so uh i guess there's a lot of
hope on the part of ukrainians
to
you know to have the united states enter
the war
and united states saying no they're not
entering the war
and um
someone here made a comment
said the following he says uh
in december biden pledged military
support to ukraine if russia invaded
where is it
did biden promise military support so
uh zalensky would not yield on the minsk
agreement and allow the donetsk and lu
hanks to be independent republics
then nato and us took all of their
assets out of ukraine in early in in
late january and early february
signaling russia to invade
well you know i i disagree with this
gentleman i don't think
at any point
united states uh said they would enter
the war if they would have wanted to
enter the war they would have started
you know a long time ago they would have
started putting troops in there and
airplanes and so on and none of that
happened
uh
in fact um i don't think there's any
reason for the united states center of
the war because uh the united states
already accomplishes some objectives
the objective was not ukraine ukraine
has nothing to do with this
conflict in a way right
now this conflict is about germany and
uh
having uh germany knuckled down under
the united states so i'll just give you
my five cents worth this is my my take
on this uh ukrainian war uh usu won't
intervene military
they uh
on the one hand
they don't want to start a world war iii
but then there's uh the issue of you
know if you have us enter the war
uh then the whole world will see it as a
us versus russia war
and the united states is very
comfortable with seeing this as a russia
against ukraine war
mainly because
you know ukrainians they're they're
russians they're all russians they have
the same culture they have the same
religion they use the same uh
letters
they eat the same things borsch
they drink the vodka there's no
difference between russians and
ukrainians uh you know you might think
there is maybe ukrainians think they're
different but it's just another province
of russia that's all ukrainian ukraine
is
and uh it used to be part of the soviet
union meaning it was part of russia you
could say
governed from moscow and what happened
um
you know uh the the uh ukrainians broke
loose
and now the russians are trying to
recover
their territory so to speak
and so
the war in ukraine is just russians
killing russians and so the americans
are see eating popcorn on the sideline
just watching the show
they love it
and here they took over germany without
firing a single shot losing a single man
you know and they've been trying to get
germany to come on board for a long time
first thing they did was kill their
north stream pipeline which they were
months trying to convince the germans to
stop it
and the germans wouldn't do it and
finally through this
war
they finally achieved that then they uh
stopped the uh swift the banking system
um
they um
they they're gonna become the new energy
providers of germany and france and
of europe so united states is very happy
with that
and uh it's it compelled germany to
spend more money on its defense which
it's been trying to do for many years
now
and so you know the and on top of that
they're destroying the soviet the
russian economy so the united states has
already accomplished all its goals now
it's just uh having fun watching how the
russians kill russians
you know and they're giving some weapons
to the
ukrainians they're not giving them
billions of dollars they just gave them
300 million dollars worth of equipment
and uh so
the russians have billions
of uh
dollars in in machinery going into
ukraine i mean you're not going to stop
them with a few million dollars okay
so uh
you know again uh the united states has
no reason to enter the war because it's
already achieved its goals its goals
were to conquer germany and primarily
and france second it's already done that
uh
germany has lost its sovereignty now to
the united states it has to follow
orders from washington it's going to
rely on
u.s energy sources pay for them a little
higher
it's got to change its economics because
again it can't use this swift system to
trade with the russians so there's been
a lot of changes but a lot of them here
in germany
and uh you know a lot of people are not
aware of that because that's not in the
news
at least as much as the war and what's
going on in russia
so yeah this was bad for russia and it
was bad for
germany and probably
i would think also for france
uh the united states is very happy with
us
so
no i don't think uh
the united states is going to enter the
war it never intended to
enter the war and uh so you know i don't
know where he got this thing that you
know the
united states promised in fact it
promised the opposite said it wouldn't
enter the war it made it very clear and
i don't think it will go into the war no
need to
and the war is doing just fine as it is
right now
as far as the americans are concerned
okay someone says putin is the smartest
world leader under the minsk agreement
he has the right to
demilitarize ukraine to do that all he
has to do is eliminate the government of
kiev without taking away
other cities if he wanted to crush
ukraine he would have done so by now
putin's government has said it has no
plans on occupying ukraine putin still
has not taken any major city
well you know um uh
again
one of the issues there i think is uh
you bummed the hell out of the cities
well there's not much to take
after the war is over you know so
i i guess they they're trying to measure
maybe uh
how much they destroy
that could be one issue i mean i'm just
speculating here but that is something
that you gotta think about
but i'm worried about this uh putin
who's the smartest world is the smartest
world leader well he's a smart guy he's
been there in power 20 years
but
you know this is
smartness is is not
always helpful
in politics okay
sometimes the circumstances of what's
going on in a country
overcomes
any smart person out there that stands
in the way you know it happened to
gorbachev you know he
he was overthrown and he was a pretty
smart cookie i would say and he was
overthrown by his own military guys
and uh and
ministers and so on and this could
happen to putin in fact it's very likely
do not do not be surprised if there's a
coup
uh that in
in russia and moscow and
i i'm really you know i've had some
experience with this in the background i
can only give you my five cents worth
and that is that i can almost put my
hand in the fire
that there are um
military and
whispering
in the background in moscow
and they're probably not very happy with
putin
this guy's been in power for 20 years
and they might decide to remove him
you know and change course of events do
not be surprised i think the there's
always conspiracies going on but
especially in these circumstances where
you have um
um you know the uh a war on the one hand
and a destroyed economy on the other
possibly a recession or depression
coming around over there you know so
i don't know a lot of these generals
will be looking at that and they might
decide to you know
take them out it could be even an
assassination for all we know okay
so uh please do not put it past them it
won't help them with all these
intelligence if uh
if they overthrow okay so that's
i'm sure that's in the works already now
if if uh if it materializes that's a
separate issue but i'm convinced that
there are people in high places
that are murmuring you know and maybe uh
if they find a chance you know an
opportunity in there they might take it
and uh overthrow or even kill
i mean so
keep that in mind
anyways here we have another foul says
the americans never did the nato
uh punish they said they would do
uh just sanctions russia is looking
strong they are really going in to make
their slavic uh block a thing the ussr
is coming back
yeah
just kidding probably not
but a bigger slavic uh
powerhouse is indeed coming
well i don't know about that you know i
talked about that the other day a little
bit and uh
here again i can tell you that russia
has had its share of revolutions
let me get it here fell on the other
side again give me a second
obs
okay
and uh
these are some of the revolutions the
russians had over the years over the
centuries
okay and you can see there's uh
every now and then you get a revolution
in russia you know how many revolutions
has the united states had
and so um
another revolution maybe especially when
uh this situation resembles in many ways
that of nicholas ii you know where uh
things were so bad especially
economically
that they finally decided to remove them
they asked them to
renounce his kingship his starship
and it could happen to uh poutine you
know it's
don't put it past them
it could really happen
okay another uh
just wondered if people are still
hearing me
sometimes they pull the plug on me okay
uh another foul says china not becoming
a world superpower
is truly an unavoidable fact in other
words he believes that china will become
a superpower
and i think it is to some degree already
from an economic point of view no doubt
about that the question is whether
the united states is going to allow
china to surpass it especially
militarily
that's where
[Music]
i think that's where we approach the end
of the world because i think that's
where you might have a world war three
and the other thing you have to
think about is that you know china
right now is trying to help russia out
but these things happen in the past as
well uh there could be a betrayal there
you know
maybe uh
for whatever real interest china decides
to
backstab uh russia it's a possibility
uh
may not happen now because maybe china
needs russia on its side if it's going
to fight its war against the united
states
but again if the united states happens
to put enough pressure on russia and
there's an overthrow of the government
in russia which is what the united
states is really hoping for as the final
uh outcome of this war
uh
one friendly to the west maybe and then
you have you know everybody's friends
again everybody's brothers again we're
all friends and then the only enemy
remaining is china so
china might not want russia to collapse
but again
sometimes there are different interests
out there and betrayals are not unheard
of
okay another file says if europe stops
buying uh russian gas
russia will sell it to china
uh-huh yeah they've i'm sure they
arranged that before the war okay
putin did go to china and he talked with
z you know so
yeah it's very likely that that's
already in the works
um
we'll they're talking about making a
pipeline also but that's going to take
some time
i'm not sure
the people in russia can wait that long
you know start that long
okay so
and europe will buy the gas from the
middle east uh that china would have
bought yeah probably uh the united
states is gonna be the middle man there
the united states is gonna make uh some
uh
risk business selling energy to europe
once it settles there should only be a
small medium price increase for the cost
of transporting the gas by sea as lng
uh yeah all i can tell you about that is
that um
i think it's been a lot more expensive i
don't think it's going to be that that
cheap for germany especially italy you
know to buy gas
uh
from the arabs when they had the
pipeline there just serving it directly
to their houses you know i mean it's a
big difference there
there are plans to build pipelines
across the mediterranean from the middle
east to europe yeah
i'm not sure we can all wait for the
plans we got to find out what's going to
go what happened to this war right
supposedly russia wants to trade gas in
euros rather than dollars but after the
ukraine war i think they'll change their
mind yeah they've created a new bank
over there in uh in
russia new banking system that is going
to replace
this swift deal okay
we'll see what happens with that if that
doesn't work uh you know maybe the
collapse of the soviet of the russian
economy okay
okay and uh here we have uh this file
says
the economy collapsing is equivalent to
a heart stopping as it's the end of
circulation yes uh the analogy is a
human being dies when his heart stops
well maybe that's what the economy
stopping uh does to the world okay i
think in that sense it's a good analogy
with the cause of the stoppage or why we
can't grow anymore be considered the
reason we died
famine uh starvation plague war
market crash
low return on energy material investment
etc okay
yeah um
a human being
is a good analogy when his heart stops
so does the
body you know the rest of the body and
the person collapses and dies
and
you could say that
the
i would say more than the heart the
in the case of the global economy it's
more like the blood of a human being you
know
what we have is money we have trade and
money and trade is what keeps the world
running
and one of the problems i see now is
that you know again
how do i
propose extinction is going to happen
well it's going to be food it's going to
be food and it's going to be because
trade stops
we won't accept currency anymore at some
point we lose confidence in money money
disappears okay
now just take that as an assumption for
a second
and
uh first thing there you need to
understand that if there's no money if
there's no circulation of money if
nobody accepts money of any kind
gold uh
diamonds
you know bitcoin whatever nobody accepts
any kind of exchange
then we're all dead
and a lot of people have a lot of
trouble understanding that they think
that we can run the world without trade
without money without currency
and you know i think they have a lot to
learn
but
the issue is that if money dies which is
what i call the economic collapse when i
talk about economical acts i'm not
talking about depression or recessions
or anything like that any petty thing
i'm talking about total elimination of
money
that's what i mean by collapse okay and
so if if
we have a an economic collapse if nobody
accepts money anymore you know suddenly
you know you have all these corporations
and they have no incentive to produce
food aside from the fact that they have
nothing to pay their employees with
because remember money is no more so the
employees won't accept money why would
they work if they don't work who
produces or distributes the food
that's the essence of the theory okay
and so the question is whether uh all
these measures that all these countries
are taking now especially you know
the fact that they're blocking one
country blocks the other
some commerce here today another over
there they they
raise all these sanctions you know they
implement these sanctions
and so the question is is is that good
for the global economy
you know and so this is where you got to
look at whether you know
we're approaching a point of no return
as far as the global economy okay
i don't think we can continue
you know uh just
threatening other countries to say oh we
won't do commerce with you because all
we're doing is kind of making the world
into these little pockets
and each one tries to solve their own
problems locally
you know instead of growing and becoming
uh an international thing it's gonna be
more like a local thing
we're stopping commerce not increasing
commerce in other words and uh that
might work against all of us okay
anyways uh here's a
another take that i've got on the
extinction of man okay
here's uh
our population
population
since at least the beginning of the
christian era okay
and that's more or less what the curve
looks like we're like eight billion
people now
question is what's going to happen
uh
after today okay
are we going to continue growing are we
going to level off we're going to go
down to extinction that's the question
i'm asking
and here you see the three trends these
are the only three possible outcomes
okay we either continue growing okay
population wise right we could more or
less run around back and forth around a
a constant number maybe eight or nine
billion people you know whatever
or we can go down to extinction
and which will which will happen
and the first thing i'm going to tell
you is i don't think we're going to live
a million more years
and i think anyone who thinks that
humans are going to be around in a
million more years here on earth is
crazy he doesn't have the slightest clue
okay i don't even think we're gonna live
another thousand years okay
so i'm gonna proceed with that okay i'm
gonna proceed with the idea the notion
that
uh
we're not uh humans are gonna become
extinct anytime from here
to
before three the year three thousand
we're in the year two thousand two
thousand twenty two right we're not
going to make it to three thousand
twenty two that's that's what what i'm
gonna put my bet on okay
and again that's gonna be an assumption
here and the question is
let's assume that's assumption is
correct
will it be very very soon
or will it be closer to 3000 to the year
three thousand would be the year two
thousand eight hundred maybe two
thousand five hundred
you know uh when do you think it's going
to happen
and for those of you who believe that um
that it will happen
sometime maybe in the future maybe not
in your lifetime
well you get only one question to answer
and that is
what is going to cause it
what is the mechanism that's going to
kill man that man cannot avoid
we can avoid nuclear weapons we just
don't throw them
very simple
uh we can avoid asteroids probably we
can nuke them before they reach the
earth we spot them newcome get get rid
of them
there are things we can do about
catastrophes i don't think a volcano is
going to kill us
you know i don't think uh there's going
to be plumes coming out of the bottom of
the ocean
methane or whatever and uh
you know poisoning the atmosphere
so what is the mechanism that's going to
kill man assuming you agree that men is
not going to live forever and you may
even agree that we won't make it to the
year 3000. what's what's gonna kill us
what's the mechanism
give me a mechanism okay
and uh with that i'm gonna continue now
with uh
the recap for the month of february what
we did in physics
okay and so here's an outline okay what
we did okay
these are the um
the um
issues that we touched upon okay
first ones or one of them was
explanation is not equal to a
description okay
and uh we have a problem with that
because mathematics can only describe
and people
receive a description and they think
they walk away thinking they got an
explanation
that's a big problem it's a serious
problem today in in
in this whole debate about physics and
so on
people take descriptions in lieu of
explanations and they walk away thinking
well i just didn't understand because i
did not know enough math or whatever
no you're not getting an explanation we
have no explanation for gravity we have
no explanation rational explanations uh
if it's irrational it's not an
explanation at all you know if we're
gonna introduce uh god and the angels or
black magic then we don't have an
explanation you know that is not an
explanation we're talking about
mechanisms that you can visualize
objectively and so if we don't have that
we don't have that for gravity we don't
have that for
the workings of the atom we don't know
what an atom looks like in other words
when i say we i'm talking about the
mathematicians okay
and so they have no clue
uh what magnetism is what electricity is
they don't have a single clue about any
of those things
so what have they done over the years
well they've introduced
uh words such as energy mass force field
charge
wave you know the worse the time you
know they look they introduce these
words which are all concepts
and they they do physics with concepts
they move concepts around people don't
realize that they think they're getting
an explanation and they're not it's an
irrational
in fact description because those words
are all descriptive words none of them
are explanatory words okay
and so um
here we have uh an example okay um
we have this um
in philosophy you know uh i gave the
example of romeo and juliet you know you
don't know what's going through their
minds
they commit suicide right they die
and uh well you know the description is
what you see in the in the frame of the
film or in the
book
and it says you know that they killed
each other or whatever they killed each
each one killed himself or whatever you
know and so the the issue is that's the
description
but you can't see inside the mind of
someone and find out what was going on
in there you don't know the reason the
the purpose okay that's what i'm saying
and imagine a detective going to a
scene of a crime
well
what's objective is the description he
can say okay there's a dead body here
and got a knife stuck to his back and et
cetera et cetera that he can describe
but he doesn't know what caused it or
what
and even if they find a killer he
doesn't know what went through the guy's
mind
okay so that's something you cannot
describe
that's something you have to explain
and what i'm saying that reasons and uh
purposes as well as in physics causes
you know
you can't answer with a description
for those kinds of things you need an
explanation
you know we don't have for example in
the case of physics you have a spoon
fall to the floor
and so what do they say well they say
they give you a description they say
force equals mass mass divided by
distance squared well that's a
description
you know you you tell me how much was
the force
based on how much mass the spoon had how
much mass the earth had you haven't told
me absolutely anything about the
mechanism you haven't told me anything
about the causes
and that's uh that's where we failed
today in science and official science
and that official saying says that you
know uh we have warped space we have
negative momentum transfer these are the
explanations if if you call these those
irrational
uh explanations mechanisms explanations
at all
okay
and so
what i'm saying is yeah again uh and i
raised this because uh in jfg
um jf garippi he said that um
a an explanation is just a series of
descriptions and the argument that my
counter argument to that was that um
a frame of the film
you can describe
but the explanation is the entire film
so from that point of view an
explanation already is not equal to a
description but what a description
cannot do at all is answer causes and
uh
reasons in the case of velocity
okay so that's where i draw the line
okay so uh
that's one issue
another issue was this issue about
gravity and in order to get to that i
brought up uh mr kant okay
and he said uh unmediated attraction
that's what he talked about in the 18th
century okay unmediated attraction what
the hell is that well it's uh action at
a distance that's what it is
and uh so
these were essentially the main points
uh
can't uh try to do push and pull are the
only forces we can imagine
and today you hear um
what uh four forces
i thought there were only two forces
push and pull
and uh today you have what push-pull
maybe and perhaps
you you've got four forces in quantum
mechanics one is the weak force the
other one is a strong force when you
look at them they're also push and pull
what does the gluon do the
strong force it pulls what does the push
the
weak force do it pushes
so we have push pull
that's physics now for these people to
say well these are different forces from
a mathematical point of view or from
whatever
it doesn't concern physics physics
there's only push and pull
okay and so
we're in line with
emmanuel kent
and uh quantum mechanics is not
then it says uh he said pool doesn't
really you use the word attraction but
i'm going to use the word pull
doesn't readily lend itself to our
senses you know we can all pretty much
understand you know
two objects like two balls pushing
surface to surface
that's what kent was saying
this is really
visualizable we can we can imagine this
you know we can see it watch it we can
understand it what we cannot understand
is how this ball can pull on that one
from a distance without any mediator
unmediated attraction as he called it
okay that's where we have problems with
pull
push is easy and push is really not that
easy if you come to think of it because
if you have discrete particles
what compels one particle
to
approach another one and push
it pull again
i mean how does one particle that is
discrete now you have a whole bunch of
discrete particles you know you have a
sandbox
particles separated by space how does
one particle get another one push on
another one
okay so that's not easy either but much
harder is to explain pull that's where
people say yeah you can't pull with two
discrete particles
okay and that's when these people
invented all these concepts that well
it's mass
it's gravity it's waves
so you know they invented these concepts
to explain something physical that's
what they did okay and that's what we
have today
irrational
explanations um
and
the the issue there is that you can't
see or touch the mediator or pull that's
what kant was saying
and he called that unmediated attraction
you have two objects but there's nothing
in between you have the moon and the
earth or you have the earth and the sun
there's nothing in between
that kant
could see or touch
that was the issue
so that's where he missed uh you know
you know making a point he thought that
because he couldn't see anything
or touch anything between the earth and
the moon or between the earth and the
sun
that there was nothing there
and the problem there is that he ran
with the wrong definition an irrational
definition of the word object of what a
thing is
so he called it unmediated attraction
and unmediated attraction is known as
black magic
okay that's what unmediated uh
attraction is
uh so but he did say that you can't
explain paul using push
and he made a long argument on that you
gotta read his book okay i'm not gonna
go over all the details but he uh he
explains why you cannot explain
paul by using push you know people say
you know in fact there it is the
lucretius was probably the first
person to mention something like that in
writing you know uh he he lived around
um
50
40 years before
the christian era okay
and
then years later you have this fellow
fascio he was
newton's right-hand man nicholas facio
and he did all the experiments for
newton and he also came up with this
revived luprecious theory of this what i
call shadow
mechanism of pull
which uh i'll show you in a second here
and let's sage
came up with it a
a few years later uh and many years
later casimir uh used it to explain
electromagnetism certain what is known
as the casimir effect all these are
shadow
mechanisms
and so what is the shadow mechanism well
here let me show it to you
okay
it looks like this you have particles
pushing things from the outside
and all you have to do is wipe out the
particles between them and the particles
from the outside push inwards that's the
essence of the mechanism okay
and so the question is whether
this and so
this is what
kant was saying you cannot explain pull
like this like saying the donkey is not
pulling on on the little man there uh
by
using this uh contorted uh
push mechanisms uh from the outside okay
so
that's what kant was against and he
makes a strong argument of why that's
not the case you cannot try to explain
this pull
between two objects by using push
and a lot of people who have never read
candle print apparently uh they
uh they reinvent le sage type mechanisms
or casimir type mechanism even to this
day and they say oh i discovered
something new something new that's been
around since the days of lucretius and
yeah you cannot explain it with
particles
which is what these people are trying to
do they're trying to explain pull with
push what are they
what are they going to use for push
they're going to use particles okay so
it's all about particles the so-called
ether and that's what it was all about
okay and here you have it uh
you know this is the magic of gravity
uh
action at a distance
is known as black magic if you or
unmediated attraction as kind called it
it's known as black magic
because you're introducing in that same
space you're essentially introducing
uh
spirits you're introducing god you're
introducing the magic wand that's what
you're doing
and so
you know you cannot explain this
by saying there's no mediator in there
uh the correct uh analysis of this is
that you can't see or touch
the mediator that's different than
saying that there is no mediator okay so
let's separate those two
okay and uh what they do is they explain
these things with concepts they say well
there's uh this field
there's this energy there's this force
time you know and so on warp space
uh waves you know this is how they
explain this and that's not an
explanation those are descriptions
because all those words are mathematical
words they're concepts of mathematics
that's why those are not
physical interpretations
they're abstract interpretations okay
and
yeah you can't mediate with concepts
using any of those concepts you have to
have a mediator otherwise you're doing
it with black magic
okay and people don't like that me
saying that because they say what do you
mean you know i've got this theory and
the theory is push gravity or or
whatever and they can't explain that
either because they can't tell you why
the particle's moving to begin with why
is one particle approaching another and
you still have pull there right
why would the particles move in a given
direction
okay so you have to explain the
mechanism okay
that's the issue
and here we have uh
another
version of that you know you have two
particles there green one and a white
one
okay put all the particles you want
how are you going to produce pull
with discreet particles that's the
million dollar question okay
can you do it
and i'm saying that no you can't
you can't rationalize it okay so anyone
who tries to do
pull with particles
is gonna have to break his brain quite a
bit okay
and yeah
you have to also explain to begin with
why
a single particle would move to begin
with
okay
now you can say it's already in motion
no problem it's in motion and what it's
going to cause a domino effect this one
hits that one which it's that one which
it's that one is that what it is and
what direction does it hit and how about
the other direction
so you're going to have problems with
particles no doubt about it you can't
produce pull with particles anyway you
twist it or turn it or stand on your
head you won't be able to do it it's
impossible not in a rational way now if
you introduce the you know the magic
wand
where is it
there if you introduce the magic one and
wave it and say abracadabra yeah then
you can do it you can't do it rationally
okay uh so
then we covered also dark matter and the
problem there is that uh we had dark
matter and dark energy and essentially
those two
are they start by saying we don't know
what it is but then they tell you what
it is
it's a contradiction here it is okay
they say we don't know what it is what
is dark matter we don't know what it is
and then they tell you what it is they
say it's uh heavy it's particles and
they're dark
actually invisible
transparent translucent because you can
see right through the
uh halo that you see there around the
galaxy
so you know
i'm the first person on earth to tell
them what it is because they say we're
looking for we don't know exactly what
it is but we're looking for it and i'm
the first person on earth who's telling
them what it is i found out what it is
please give me my novel okay
what is it it's dark
it's a particle and it weighs a lot
give me my note
i found out what it is
okay
yeah because they tell you that it's
particles they already know that they
proved it they they're convinced of that
since particles they weigh a lot there
we know that now and they're tar that's
why they call them dark
and that's the only condition we need to
change we got to say they're invisible
uh transparent translucent those are
better words
and so we know what they are particles
which have are heavy and translucent
we know what it is
so how do they say we don't know what it
is
and they don't know what it is but
they're looking for it
it's like you know doing an experiment
before doing a design of experiment you
know for every experiment you got to do
a design for experiment first especially
if it's going to cost money because you
got to propose it to your boss who's got
to propose it to the higher-ups and say
well they're going to spend a million
dollars doing this experiment are we
going to pay for it well what is it
about
and so you got to present the design the
doe as it's called the design of
experiment so it's approved it's get the
stamp
and you get the funds for it that's the
way it works then you go out and do the
experiment these people are looking for
stuff and they said we don't know what
we're looking for we don't know what it
is but we're looking for it
i'm looking for my cat what's a cat i
don't know but i'm looking for it okay
[Laughter]
that's dark matter and dark energy in a
nutshell for you they're looking for
stuff that they don't know what it is
even though they tell you what it is
so it's the complete contradiction
circular argument whatever you want to
call it
uh
they already tell you what it is it's uh
particles that are out in the outside
and a periphery of a galaxy that serve
two purposes one it prevents
uh stars from flying out especially from
the periphery and the other one is it
makes them go faster around the galaxy
than stars on the inside
and what are they they're particles
they're heavy
and
they're either dark or transparent so we
know what they are
but then they tell you they don't know
what it is and they're looking for it
okay
is the world crazy or what
we don't know what it is but we're
looking for it okay
okay uh and here's a
more dark matter uh the other side of
the coin really this is the dark energy
uh point that we covered the other day
and that's what's pushing the universe
out since the big bang is known as dark
energy and what are those those are also
particles particles that are dark that's
why it's dark energy right and what is
energy made of particles obviously
and so they have all this dark matter
that's pulling everything in and what's
pushing outwards is the dark energy and
right now the dark energy apparently is
uh overcoming gravity so you can
actually call it anti-gravity that's
what dark energy is because if gravity
is what pulls all the galaxies towards
each other then what pushes
everything outwards has to be
anti-gravity so we also know what what
dark energy is it's anti-gravity that's
what it's called
you know and so these people already
have all these concepts out there and
they tell you we don't know what it is
you already told me what it is
you know don't tell me again because you
already told me what it is
okay um then we talked about uh
this foul whale
bile in german whale okay
and um
he he's got a couple problems because uh
he's a mathematician well he died
already a long time ago but um
he wrote a book and i think you have got
the book
uh somewhere
oh no i don't have it
there it is maybe
let's see if this is it yeah
and he wrote a book it's called um
space-time matter okay
and uh he in that book he starts out
with geometry the rudimentary of
geometry and he starts out saying what a
point is what a line is and this is
going to be important for the issue of
the axis of rotation or spin of the moon
some people say you know whether the
moon spins or not and so um
what whale did he says uh he defines
what a straight line is he says its
distinguishing feature is that it is
determined by two of its points so if
you have two points right you have a
line thus if a and b are two different
points the straight line
uh g equals uh a b includes every point
in other words every point in between
uh i don't know where he got the extra
points he put him in there by hand but
essentially he's not talking about
points he's talking about locations
they call them points why because
they're going to represent them with a
dot okay
and he says the straight line lies
evenly between its points expressed
kinematically this is 10 amount to
saying that we regard the straight line
as an axis of rotation okay so he's got
these row of apples that's a notion of
row of apples but then further on he he
screws up completely because he has a
different notion of what a straight line
is he says we may say that a straight
line is derived from a point but in by
an infinite repetition of the same
infinitesimal translation in its inverse
so he's going to talk about motion of a
point motion of a location if you can
imagine that a location that moves very
scary stuff and that's different than
the row of apples so we're talking about
an itinerary
and he calls both these notions these
these irreconcilable notions he calls
them lines okay
and so the question is which of these
two is going to be the axis of rotation
is it going to be the
row of apples or the
itinerary described by one apple okay
he says a plane however is derived by
translating one straight line okay along
another
uh in the case of rotation for example
the points on the axis are distinguished
by the property that they preserve their
positions
okay
so we got a problem with uh
with several notions here and it's
what's wrong with essentially what's
wrong with um
geometry which is an attempt to merge
the language known as mathematics with
the science known as physics
and those two will never meet they have
nothing to do with one another and
that's where the problem is geometry was
the first attempt
that our
ancestors way back when
they tried to merge these two things
they said look let's take mathematics
let's measure the land because that's
what geometry means the measurement
essentially that's what it was used for
measuring the land
and they started doing calculation they
started doing measurements and they
related to physics because they were
measuring something physical you know
the the land in this case or it could
have been a building or whatever so this
is how
mathematics got merged
with physics
and the problem there is that you have
the point
and they have to create this monster
called the point and the point they say
today that it's an undefined
notion concept whatever
and why is it undefined why do they say
that well they say that because the
point they say is zero dimensional
or like uh euclid said that which has no
part
right so we have this zero dimensional
no part point
and say okay what is a point
well it's a dot
it's a dot and the dot is either two
dimensional or three dimensional
so we have a zero dimensional
point
represented pictorially by a two or
three dimensional dot
and is the dot
the point
and they say no the that is actually
representing a location a
non-dimensional
location because a location has no
dimensions not a physical object
so we have what let's see if we get it
straight we got a dot
that is two-dimensional or
three-dimensional representing a concept
which is non-dimensional
and they call that a zero dimensional uh
point
and it doesn't stop there then they take
that point like mr uh
whale did and he goes in there and he uh
takes this dot this zero dimensional
point
and he constructs a one dimensional line
yeah you heard right we got zero
dimensional points nothing there it's
going to construct a one-dimensional
line which is also nothing
and the question is are we have are we
looking at a row
of dots are we looking at a row of
locations
meaning
motion
what is the line
this is the problem we don't have a good
definition that's why they say well we
don't know we don't have a definition
for a line we don't have a definition
for point we don't know what it is of
course you don't know what it is because
you mixed
an abstraction with something solid
which is the dot right in in one case
and the other one you take a plane which
is a
this elongated uh
rectangle known as a line and you're
representing
which is two-dimensional and you're
representing a one-dimensional concept
known as a line
okay
what is the problem with all this well
the problem comes when we do
spin we talked about the spin of the
moon and people don't know whether the
moon spins or not and here are the
different possibilities we have
three types of people we have the flat
earthers okay and they believe that
humans did not go to the moon
uh did not even go to space
okay and they say humans haven't gone to
space because we can't make it there
right one of the reasons is that they
say that we have radiation vacuum and
temperature
and we have the moonies they say usually
the same thing that those are the
reasons we haven't gone to the moon
they do believe that we
went to space
a lot of these moonies uh are not flat
earthers and they do believe the
uh earth is round etc etc but those are
the two groups but then you have the uh
third group which is the what i call the
loonies okay we have the moonies and the
loonies the loonies are people who
believe the moon spins
okay
and no the moon does not spin
and
the question is why have the
mathematicians never discovered that
well they never discovered it because
they never defined the word spin that's
what it comes down to their definition
is no good especially for physics
and that's why you never leave uh
mathematicians define things for physics
okay because they have no clue what's
the issue the issue is that like mr
whale said you know
um
a one-dimensional line cannot be used in
physics
and what they do is they use this
concept of mathematics which we don't
know if it's a row of apples
or an itinerary of an apple okay and i
think i have one here
uh yeah
so we don't know if the axis that they
talk about the one-dimensional axis is
this you know is it a row of apples or
is it an itinerary of an apples
of an apple is it two points which
have many points in between
if the points are locations are we
talking about motion are we talking
about
uh dots
what is this what is the line what is
this famous axis and no matter which
what i put in there it's not
one-dimensional
in fact no one can come up with a
one-dimensional anything okay this is
the issue no one can come up with that
because
people say well i can imagine it no you
can't because if you can imagine it hey
very simple you know show us show us a
piece of your mind okay that's what you
got to do okay so
that's the issue of uh
that you know that
creates problems when people try to
figure out whether the moon spins or not
okay does the moon spin or not and in
the case of mathematical physics they
say yeah the moon spins and you say well
why does it spin well because it rotates
around the earth in 27 days and so it
made one full turn around its own axis
it spins very slowly but it does spin
that's the argument that's the logic
if you can call it logic
and no the answer is no the moon does
not spin okay and the question is why
well we have to define what spin means
and for that you have to look at the
this axis
and the problem there is the question
whether the axis itself
spins
does an axis spin
and of course if you have a
one-dimensional axis which you cannot
even
imagine because you can't
put it on paper you can't bring it to
the conference you can't bring a
one-dimensional anything
uh put it out here for for us to see it
objectively and
have an idea what you're talking about
well much less if you can't put it out
here much less can you talk about it's
spinning on its axis
the does the
does the axis spin on its axis that's
the question okay why is that important
well because the mathematician when they
talk about spinning and angular momentum
and all this other stuff they don't even
look at the axis at all
they're not interested in the axis per
se what they're interested in is
distance
and not even distance distance traveled
what they want to know is how much
distance how much separation is there
between the so-called axis which they're
going to use as the frame of reference
you know to
the edge
of whatever you to the surface
point on the surface a location on the
surface that's going to be supposedly
rotating spinning okay
so they're just going to look at
distance does the distance change
that's what they're going to be looking
at
and the question there is if the
distance
does not change
the thing cannot be rotating
if the distance changes
then the thing is rotating spinning okay
and so the the question there is you
need to know whether that axis is
spinning as well because with a
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
axis you can talk about the spinning of
the axis if i drive a stake right
through the
moon and i keep it steady you know god's
steak
just a little cylinder that i drive
right through the center of the moon
does
its rotation around
its orbit actually around the earth
27 days
does the moon at any point
change any of the
locations on its surface with respect to
that axis if the axis is standing still
and the answer is no the the the moon
moves together with the axis
so if if we were to look at that uh i
think i've got a picture here
okay yeah
this is what you would see you would see
that uh
the one that's wrong there the red one
okay the one on the upper right
that's that's uh
not what happens with the uh with the
moon the moon
would would rotate like the one on the
left where the axis turns together with
the moon
okay because that's the the moon always
shows the same face
to
uh whatever point on the axis you want
to
select it always has the same
uh distance no matter what when it turns
around the sun
that's different than the earth which
changes locations on its surface with
respect to a fixed axis
so the moon doesn't
spin like like a top
at not at all slowly or fast at all
it always has the same
point on the surface pointed to the same
location on a three-dimensional axis on
a one-dimensional axis we don't know
because there is no such thing as a
one-dimensional axis you cannot imagine
a one-dimensional axis
spinning on its axis
and so it's uh pointless to talk about
the one-dimensional axis of mathematics
and again it's because they introduce
concepts into physics that we have these
problems where people say well does the
moon spin or not well you can't use the
concepts of mathematics especially when
spin
is a physical phenomenon belongs
exclusively to physics and not at all to
mathematics
okay and then you have the issue you
know where they have atoms where
they say the electron spins and you say
okay it spins like a top you mean and
the answer is no uh spin is a number
that we assign to spin
we have sine minus half we assign plus
half you know we have all these values
for spin
does your top have a half spin
or or a positive half spin minus half
spin
a one spin
what spin does your top have
so yeah this is the problem the problem
is you can't mix the notions of
mathematics and introduce them into
physics
and spin is one of them okay
okay uh let me get on with some of the
questions and uh
issues that people raised since last
time apollo says see if we can put it up
here
the connecting atoms with ropes does not
explain why an atom is pulled towards
the earth and not towards the trillions
of atoms in the rest of the universe
my god
for poor fellow i mean here we're
talking about distance he doesn't
understand that he doesn't understand
that all the ropes come together very
simple concept and
file doesn't get it okay if anything
this rope model would lead to a static
universe where everything is suspended
like in a spider web the orbits of
planets and moons are not fixed like
spider web or carousel yeah no kid
the moon for instance is always changing
its distance from the earth yeah okay
what is the mechanism by which an atom
is pulled in any given direction if
there are no motors attached to the
ropes
poor follow i mean i don't know how many
times i gotta explain this but here it
goes okay
um okay that's how gravity works
essentially all atoms
are physically interconnected okay and
then at great distances all the ropes
come together that's why
the
square of the distance
notion that newton has in his equation
the famous gravitational equation has to
do with distance inverse
proportionally inversely to uh to
distance that's what i'm saying
okay so uh that's the notion okay and
when they're close together all the uh
ropes come together so here's a dynamic
version okay just an example okay
and here it is a person falling to earth
okay in this case an astronaut
as he falls the ropes
uh
act individually they're no longer on
the same axis
that's the issue that's acceleration of
gravity right there okay
so that's the mechanism i'm not sure
what problem this fellow has uh he
believes that the rest of the universe
is pulling on the guy yes it is also
they're not pulling or they're really
under tension but
we can use the word pull for the sake of
argument here the point is they're so
far away
that's the issue the moon is very far
away from the astronaut and so the earth
pulls much stronger on the astronaut
than all the ropes in the universe
because of distance distance makes the
difference
okay
and here we have uh again
file says there's neither a push nor
pull because both objects are
accelerating towards a null pressure
point between the objects
okay that's the no i guess that's what
he's referring to the low pressure point
where the ropes essentially criss-cross
okay the the majority of roads remember
there are ropes going straight as well
we put them the main ones should go in
that direction what you see there in
that pattern okay and he's saying
there's a no pressure point i guess he's
referring to that says uh point is the
connection point or
the tether of the threads in the rope
okay
and so uh he's saying um this should be
a static situation
there should be no motion from one
object to the other because they're all
essentially being pulled you could say
right towards that uh pressure point
there that's his argument okay
okay so what's the problem okay let's
first show the earth going around the
sun here
okay and so we have again you can see it
there you can see the pressure point
that this fella's talking about
i i think that's what he's talking about
i don't want to put words completely in
his mouth maybe he'll clarify next time
but that's what i'm going to assume now
that that's the pressure point right
there where the ropes meet
and you can see that the earth is not
falling towards the sun
why because the earth
the sun is
swinging the earth around itself
so you have this centrifugal
force
being counteracted by the centripetal um
connection there you could say okay
which are the ropes okay and that's why
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system because these two
essentially
even out one is trying to get out and
the other one is pulling in okay that's
essentially what you're seeing there
now what is the issue the issue is what
if um we have this situation
where
there is no upward motion
okay
the sun is no longer swinging the earth
around itself
so this fellow says that in this case
we're going to have the same situation
the earth is going to maintain the same
distance as if
it be it were swung around the earth
around the sun
so what so what he's saying is whether
the sun swings the earth around and
whether
they they stand still uh in the middle
of space
um
the effect is gonna be the same the
earth is not going to fall towards the
sun in this case
and so that's i want you to ponder that
that's one issue i want you to ponder
the other issue you should ponder is
uh the question of um
if if we don't put ropes there what are
you proposing the alternative
what do you expect to have if not ropes
connecting every atom
uh
why doesn't the earth fly out of the
solar system that's what i want you to
answer okay
so there's uh two issues one is the
issue of whether
those two scenarios are the same okay
swinging you know
if i swing this ball around
is that the same thing as not swinging
it will this not fall towards my fingers
that's the issue here okay
and the other one is whether
if we get rid of the ropes we don't do
it with rogue we don't do gravity with
ropes
what do you propose to replace the ropes
with
uh warp space maybe
now what are you looking for
i mean how how do you plan to explain
gravity
if we don't do it with rose uh we do
what particles we do it with warped uh
time
what's what do you plan to use instead
give me a solution not only a criticism
okay
so this is
one of the things people like to
criticize but they have nothing to
propose in exchange
and of course not because you can't
oppose what is and what is is that every
atom has to be connected otherwise
you're doing what black magic to do
action at a distance okay action at a
distance means black magic that's all it
means you can't put a concept in there
even if you say
we do it with radiation waves okay what
are those waves are they physical
objects or are they abstract concepts
okay you can't put vectors in there
which is what the transverse wave of
mathematics is all about it's just a
bunch of trans um a bunch of uh
vectors which is magnitude and direction
that's all it is that's what a vector is
and so you can't put that you need you
need a physical object there
if you don't put a physical object
you're doing it with black magic
please try to understand before one of
us dies okay here we go fellow sentence
gravity is an
energy that we don't fully understand
yeah no kidding
and you'll never understand it as long
as you use the word energy and there are
energies we don't yet fully understand
yeah i don't think they understand
anything about energy in fact uh who was
it um
richard feynman says nobody knows what
energy is
able to measure the field okay the field
now we have we can define what it is as
a field well the problem there is that
you don't define objects you point to
them you have to point to the field you
got to tell us what a field is or what
gravity is and we're talking about the
mediator
and if it's a mediator you can't say
well it's a field because a field is not
a mediator
meal this field is not a physical object
you can't point to a field okay and if
you think otherwise just bring a field
to the conference put in the middle of
the conference room and we can all see
the field from all sides just the field
nothing else okay i don't want you
bringing the magnets i don't want you
bringing the earth
none of that just the field i want to
see what a field looks like that way we
know um
that a field is a physical object and so
yeah we don't define uh words such as uh
field or the mediator of gravity we
point to it we say that's the mediator
of gravity if you can't do it that way
you don't have a
an assumption you can't even start your
presentation because you don't know what
gravity but what gravity is is because
you don't know what it's mediated by if
you know what gravity is mediated by you
you're done
and then it's kindergarten stuff
okay the fellow continues he says we
know
uh they all know okay we know how it
operates in the universe and can utilize
the capacity to do work that's
technology has nothing to do with
science okay
so
yeah the fact that you can use
uh a magnet doesn't mean you understand
how a magnet works
yeah you can pick up things with a
magnet you can pick up pins say oh i can
do work with it yeah
but that's technology that's got nothing
to do with understanding the mechanism
of how a magnet does it and for field in
the case of gravity the same thing you
gotta you can't tell me that there's a
field between
uh the earth and the moon
field is a concept you know and what is
it a bunch of numbers in space in fact
here i have it these are the because he
says gravity is the universal force
so gravity is energy gravity is a field
gravity is a force are these all
synonyms okay
and here you see it uh
if you look up the definitions you have
energy the property capacity that must
be transferred to a body field a
quantity represented by a number that
has a value for each point in space and
time force and influence that can change
the motion of an object and influences
the capacity to become a compelling
force so we define force in terms of
influence and influence in terms of
force shows you how you can't find a
single definition scientific definition
in the dictionary they were all made by
people who were unqualified to do
definitions
you won't find them in the dictionary
anyways uh so it's an energy the same
thing as a field as a force are these
synonyms especially when uh
uh finding there says you know it's uh
important to realize that in physics
today we have no knowledge of what
energy is
so they don't know what energy is but
this fellow says that gravity is energy
gravity is a field and gravity is a
force
and they say they know they use that
word no they all know
they know everything
that's what's so funny about it they
know everything but then they say well
you know we have trouble understanding
gravity you know kidney if you're going
to say that gravity is energy what have
you said
you haven't said anything you say
gravity is a field you haven't said
anything you say gravity is a force you
haven't said anything all you're doing
is throwing words in there you know just
empty words
we need to find out what the mechanism
of gravity i need to know why this spoon
okay
falls downwards that's what i need to
explain what what comes in contact with
the skin
of the spoon that forces it downwards
and not to the seal
that's what you gotta explain
okay uh
says
i think it's saint paul yeah
weight is a measure of the force of
gravity pulling down on an object
mass is number of atoms in a body
divided by
a body
body's mass in grams by the amu atomic
mass unit right from the periodic table
then multiply the result by avogadro's
number
well i don't know where he got all that
nonsense
that's not what mass is if you look at
the international system of units okay
the unit of mass is the kilogram
doesn't say that the
uh
unit of mass is the number of atoms
see if it's the number of atoms you
would say
this object has 1 trillion atoms or 1
trillion
500 atoms
then that would be what he's saying
there that's not the way it's done
they weigh the thing and they say weighs
a kilogram
and that's especially how weight is
determined as well everybody you ask how
much a person weighs he's not going to
say well
uh
somebody newtons
no no they say i weigh 100 pounds or
whatever you know that's the way they
put it and so you know weight and mass
are identical there's no difference
between them in mathematical physics
and the reason also is because even
though they try to define
masses the quantity of atoms they never
use that the quantity of matter you know
and they never use that
the way they determine mass is by
weighing they put it on a scale and they
weigh it so if you take
uh
a ball to the moon it weighs less but it
also has less mass you say what do you
mean it has less mass yeah i waited here
on the moon and it weighs less kilograms
because that's what mass is it's
it's the values given in kilograms not
in number of atoms
does anybody count atoms before they
take the thing to the moon and say well
the number of atoms has changed or
remains the same
no because they're going to weigh it
there and based on their on the weight
which is what this while saying
that's what they're going to
you know convert to number of atoms
and so we're back to square one you know
there is no difference between weight
and mass because the mathematicians
never were able to separate
mass from weight
so those two words are synonyms until
the mathematicians are able to separate
those two
concepts
and they like to do measurements and the
way they do these things they measure
weight in the same way they measure mass
that's why they're synonyms
and they keep saying well it's not true
that they're not the same and blah blah
blah but they are the same because they
have no way of extricating mass from
weight
they have no way of doing it they never
have
okay and uh final issue uh before we get
to the questions there fellow says there
is a very famous question in
spirituality that is who am i
what is your stand on this
my stand on this is that who am i my
name is bill gatey glad to meet you
that's my take on that who am i bill
gates that's who i am
but uh you know what this is all about
really is um people
spiritual people uh
they say is is you is bill gates the
body or is bill gate the mind the spirit
the
soul or whatever you want to call it the
conscience
what other sentiment
synonyms do we have out there
you know and we have to go in physics
and physics we go with mother nature
mother nature does not recognize spirit
does not recognize consciousness does
not recognize mine she doesn't know what
nao that is all she recognizes is atoms
and then what they do which in the case
of mind
is consciousness or whatever is um
electricity and magnetism what's going
on in the brain is uh process
electromagnetic processes chemical also
right chemical electromagnetic
and although she understands okay mother
nature understands
objects things that's what she works
with she does not work with the with
what's going on in your mind
you know with this matrix notion that
you know the mind travels through the
through the wires
uh she doesn't understand that nonsense
okay the people who think like that have
watched too many hollywood movies okay
that's what it is they have they're no
longer with their feet on the ground
now mother nature only works with
objects with things
that she recognizes so um
if if i ask mother nature
to give me an objective notion of what
bill gatey is she says it's all your
atoms
and what they do in this case you know
the moving movement of the
threads like in the case of magnetism
and in the case of uh electricity uh
merged electron shells which spin in
situ that's all she understands anything
outside of that she has no idea what
you're talking about
okay
okay uh so let's see if we have some
questions today
let me look at it give me a second here
and let me go through them
ukraine uh is how russia provides the eu
and germany with their oil and gas
uh yeah could be
celenski made speaking russian illegal
could be
but a lot of people in ukraine speak uh
russian
my mother spoke both languages ukrainian
and russian she spoke fluently she spoke
also polish
i don't know how much difference there
is because
there's a lot of words that i recognize
i know a little bit of russian
that i recognize in ukrainian they use
the same letters so you know they have
it's it's almost like a dialect of
russia or russian
you know so
uh
the only reason russia is in ukraine is
because of donald trump lukansk yeah
remember these two provinces these two
states there you know
these people are
majority russians and they want to
belong to the
to russia you know
and
so that was what the war was since i
think 2014
and um
now the russians have used those groups
to move further in so they went in there
with the army now okay uh we'll see what
happens with all that
russian and ukraine's uh soldiers are
guarding chernobyl both of them yeah
maybe i think it's under the gun in the
case of the ukrainians right
uh
russia has only laid seas to kiev i
don't know uh kharkiv is also under
siege and there are a couple other
cities they talk about
uh my mother was born in
where it's loosed
in russia it's called wusk
and she was born a little town called
roshische which is up north of wusk and
they bombed woods as well so i don't
know
i think it's more than just uh kiev
by the way kiev is the pronunciation in
is the pronunciation in ukrainian and
that's why ukrainians insist that you're
calling a kiev
okay so that you know that it's a
ukrainian city not a russian city
okay
putin will not be taken out i wouldn't
put it past them but i do think that
will uh
i do not think it will happen i don't
know
um you know gorbachev also thought he
was
solid and you had this group of eight
known as the
what the gang of eight
uh china had the gang of four including
mao's wife and russia had uh the grange
of eight in fact one of them is one
person i dealt with which is uh
which was the head
of the gang of eight
uh which was kritchkov vladimir
klitschko and uh
krishkov was the guy who went there and
uh
essentially
they arrested
gorbachev while he was on vacation
and if it wasn't for the fact that
yeltsin
escaped being arrested uh
you know if he if he would have been
arrested then uh uh
klurskov would have been the new prime
minister of russia he was the head of
the kgb at the time okay so
and again gorba
he was uh surrounded by all these people
and those who were the ones who
overthrew
and that could happen to putin as well
you know all these people around him say
yes sir yes yes yes and then tomorrow
they grab them they say no sir
and it's over for him
that's the way it works
okay let's get see if we can get to the
some of the uh
questions of physics if there were any
as bill talked about walter russell
tesla has said that his books should be
locked away for a thousand years
uh
walter russell was a demented
individual you know him and his wife uh
garbage that's all they produced
none of it survives it's nonsense
poppycock all of it
so
there's nothing much to talk about
walter russell
[Music]
pressure moves all things well you gotta
explain
how pressure moves all things okay
again what is pressure caused by
particles
in what direction
okay i mean for
uh you have the solar system
are they all pushed by particles
how about the objects that go in the
opposite direction what are they pushed
by
okay
so you got to explain pressure you can't
just use the word pressure pressure is a
concept we need to know what physical
object you're going to use okay so if
you're going to use the word pressure
tell us what mediates pressure okay
hopefully you don't do it with concepts
yeah i know but to talk about pressure
is to talk about particles and to talk
about particles is nonsense if you
haven't figured out in 10 000 years that
you can't explain a single
phenomenon of physics out there with
particles
then you know
you're not even you haven't even gone to
kindergarten yet kindergarten physics
that's how simple it is straightforward
laughs
the moon rotates once on its axis on its
own axis imaginary line yeah again you
can't rotate with respect to an
imaginary line because there is you
cannot imagine it
that's why there is no such thing as an
imaginary 1d line okay and so you can't
use spin which is a issue of physics
and try to explain it with a the line of
mathematics which is the one dimensional
line which no one can imagine
not even you you cannot imagine it and i
can prove that very easily because all
you have to do is put it on paper or
bring it to the conference bring your 1d
line
okay and then we'll know what a 1d line
looks like okay no in physics there's no
such thing as a 1d line so you have to
use a 3d cylinder and then yes you have
problems because either the cylinder
uh is as thin as you want to make it is
still 3d
and you can take any location on that
cylinder if it's standing still right
right through the earth then you can
gauge the surface of the earth with
respect to that uh
with that stick
and if it changes uh locations
if it changes distances constantly is
going around then it is spinning in the
case of the moon that doesn't happen
okay so it's very simple you just got to
address the issue
and until you if you're just going to
repeat over and over
just a party line and that's all you
know how to do well there's not much you
know i can't talk to a robot
pre-programmed robot
okay uh
why are electricity and magnetism
different phenomena if they're made of
the same rope
well electricity is not made of rope
okay so you got to find out
uh
what
electricity is under the rope model
okay so electricity is not made of ropes
okay so that's where you failed okay you
gotta
you gotta read a little more watch a few
more videos find out what electricity is
and i do have videos there on
electricity what it is so
no
excuse three three four minute video
very short video you know it doesn't
take much to explain electricity is very
simple
uh you know by watching the movie that's
what i mean you know takes a million
words to explain it it takes just one
movie three-minute movie to
watch it and say oh i know what
electricity is now so no electricity is
not mediated by ropes
and actually magnetism either because
it's
mediated by threads okay
and the threads come out of the
electrons
and or
uh the ropes
that mediate between two atoms so um you
gotta understand what magnetism
electricity is before you ask the
question right now you don't
okay
see what else we have here
12 people are watching and only 11 likes
there is a traitor or so
[Laughter]
okay no uh
important scientific questions other
than that
uh if i miss one
you can always ask it later on but i
don't see that's you know just by
staring i don't see anything especially
there
okay nothing that deserves uh an answer
yeah i've answered all these questions
they're
going to like energy there there's no
no excuse for using the word energy
there is no such thing as energy in
physics okay and so
asking using the word energy in the
years
the word mass
words that are undefined which no one
knows what they are anyways uh it's
worthless and they belong to mathematics
they don't belong to uh
to science okay
science explaining how do you explain
you explain a mechanism what is a
mechanism you need to use objects what
is mathematics mathematics is numbers
and what's in between it's called
mathematics or mathematical physics and
what it is an attempt to merge physics
with math
and what they do is they introduce
concepts
um
abstract concepts which are
mathematically inclined and have
absolutely nothing to do with physics it
include the words field energy mass time
those do not belong to physics okay
physically we need to explain the
mechanism
mechanism that underlies gravity the
mechanism that underlies electricity
magnetism and for that you need only one
thing and that's to identify the objects
and if you don't put an object there
you're doing it with black magic
that's how simple it is you need an
object you need a thing
okay with that i'll see you on sunday
and if i miss the question please don't
hold it against me i'll answer it next
time we'll see you there bye